ينضم الينا من بغداد الدكتور خالد
اليعقوبي مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي
للشؤون الامنيه دكتور خالد بدايه ما هو
تعليقكم على هذه الضربه التي نفذتها ايران
في
اربيل شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه رايي هو
اللي راي اللي عبرت عنه وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه هو انتهاك واضح للسياده العراقيه
وتجاوز كبير لروح وعمق العلاقه الطيبه
اللي تجمع بين العراق وايران بالنتيجه هو
ضرب للسياده العراقيه ومساس كبير في الامن
القومي العراقي طيب كيف سيتعاطى العراق مع
ما تعتبرونه انتهاكا لسياده
العراق يعني اولا نحن نؤكد على ان المنطقه
برمتها تشهد تصعيد وفي لحظه يعني مصيريه
صعبه وفي تحديات كبيره جدا تواجه المنطقه
برمتها ثانيا الموقف العراقي كان من من
الاحداث الاخيره موقف صلب
و واضح وصريح وكان من اقوى المواقف
العربيه اللي عبر عنها السيد رئيس الوزراء
العراقي في مؤتمر القاهره وتعرض لضغوط
كبيره وقاوم هذه الضغوط الكبيره بثباته في
مواقفه الداعمه لقضيه العرب الاولى قضيه
فلسطين وباستني
للعدوان الصهيوني وما يجري في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله من قتل وتدمير ثانيا
ايران شريكه و و وعنصر دوله فاعله واساسيه
ساعدت العراق بعد عام
2014 في مواجهه اعتى التنظيمات الارهابيه
في العالم تنظيم داعش
كنا نتبادل معلوماتنا سويه كنا نقاتل سويه
اختلط الدم العراقي بالدم الايراني في
محاربه داعش فكيف للجمهوريه الاسلاميه ان
تتصرف وتحدد ان هؤلاء جواسيس وتنتهك
السياده العراقيه دون تنسيق مع الحكومه
العراقيه هذا غير مقبول اولا ونعتقد انه
في تظليل من الاجهزه الامنيه اي نقطه
جوهريه سيدتي ان ثمه ل من الاجهزه
الامنيه الاستخباريه الايرانيه لقياداته
السياسيه لفشلهم في منع الهجوم الذي تعرضت
له محافظه كرمان في ايران والذي اودى
بخسائر كبيره في وقت دكتور خالد فوالا لا
تبرير اخر بصراحه كل التبريرات عن الرد
العراقي كيف سيكون شكله
وطبيعته الرد العراقي اولا شك شكلت لجنه
تقصي حقائق برئاسه مستشار الامن القومي
والحكومه العراقيه ستحتفظ بخطواتها بعد
نتيجه هذا التحقيق الذي سيصدر خلال يوم او
يومين نتائج التحقيق بالنتيجه العراق ليس
في معزل او يعيش ل مفرده في هذا الكوكب
ربما سيرجا الى منظمات دوليه في شكوى الى
مجلس الامن الدولي الى مراجعه لطبيعه
العلاقات بين الجاره ايران والعراق على
المستويات كافه عرفين نحن مع ايران في
علاقات وطيده في هنالك ملفات في تعاون في
المجال الامني والعسكري والسياسي
والاقتصادي والتجاري والديني كل هذه حقيقه
ستكون ارض المراجعه اذ لم يتم تصحيح هذه
المواقف وتوضيحها بشكل واضح دكتور خالد
تحدثتم عن لجنه تحقيق ما الهدف من هذه
اللجنه
ما الغايه
منها يعني اولا حقيقه ما جرى في اربيل
العناصر المستهدفه في اربيل وتدعي ايران
انه عناصر تابعه للموساد
ومقار للجريمه ضدها وشفتوا انتم وكل وسائل
الاعلام شاهدت ان الضحايا هي اسره وفيها
اطفال اربعه او خمس اطفال وزوجه وضيوف
يعني حقيقه لازم تتقصى عن كل هذه الحقائق
وتفته على طبيعه الوضع وما هو الوضع دكتور
خالد تحك اقل كدست حتى تتبلور الافكار لو
سمحت لي تشكيل لجنه التحقيق يعني ان لديكم
شكوك بانه قد يكون ما قالته ايران صحيح
ليس من او استهداف ارهابيين يعني لماذا
تشكيل لجنه التقق اذا كانت اذا كن اذا كان
ما تقولون انتم متاكد
من
لا لا هي في نقطتين النقطه الاولى هو في
خرق واضح للسياده العراقيه وتجاوز على
السياده العراقيه هذا امر مرفوض وغير
مقبول على الاطلاق السياده العراقيه لا لا
تتجزا بالمس القريب نحن احتجنا يعني
مارسنا احتجاج كبير على على على الولايات
المتحده لانتهاكها السيا السياده العراقيه
في استهداف شخصيه واوقف مسا الكبيره بينه
وبين الولايات المتحده المساله الثانيه هي
مو لجنه تحقيق بقدر ما تقصي حقائق يعني
وان كانت ما تدعيه ايران وان كان صحيح
فهذا لا يجيز لها الحق بان تتجاوز على
السياده العراقيه وتمارس هكذا نوع عمليه
كان الاولى بها ان تقدم هذه المعلومات
للدوله العراقيه والدوله العراقيه تتخذ
هذه الاجراءات طيب فيما يتعلق بال المساد
وما وصفته بانه ادعاءات ما ما مصلحه ايران
في ذلك سيد
اليعقوبي انا قلت لك يعني بالنتيجه شوفي
المنطقه كلها محاولات جر بعض الاطراف لنوع
معين من الصراع العراق ثابت في مواقفه
دقيق في مواقفه يعني خطواته محسوبه بدقه
تراعي تراعي مسائل الامن القومي العراقي
وايضا امن القومي العربي وقضيتنا الكبرى
وطبيعه الصراع الكبرى فبصراحه يعني هذه
هذه المحاولات ما اعتقد صحيحه وهذه ستشكل
ضرر كبير
و بطبيعه العلاقه بين العراق وايران على
ايران ان تحترم السياده العراقيه وهذه
التجاوزات غير مقبوله واي تبرير لها
بصراحه غير مقنع بالنسبه لنا ك حكومه
عراقيه شكرا لك دكتور خالد اليعقوبي
مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي لشؤون
الامنيه كنت معنا من بغداد